bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 17 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de notre actualité les bénévoles de la
croix rouge de saint quentin en yvelines
était sur le terrain des attentats à
paris vendredi soir ils restent plus que
jamais en état d' alerte précision en
plateau avec jean-luc guislain son
président la banque alimentaire de
monkey le bretonneux à 20 ans sont
responsables viendra nous expliquer son
action luttre contre le gaspillage
partage dont est gratuite et voici
quelques-uns de ces mots d'ordre et
enfin le premier festival du film
documentaire de saint quentin en
yvelines vient de se refermer
nous ferons le bilan et trois jours
après les attentats de paris qui ont lu
le 13 novembre le président de la
république s'est adressé au parlement à
versailles dans la salle du congrès hier
après midi
françois hollande a rendu hommage aux
victimes et aux forces de l'ordre en
s'adressant aux députés et sénateurs il
a aussi multiplié les annonces notamment
sur l'état d'urgence
le point avec mélanie potier et william
l la france est en guerre
les actes commis vendredi soir à paris
et près du stade de france sont des
actes de guerre françois hollande manuel
valls claude bartolone et gérard larcher
rassemblés à versailles pour un congrès
exceptionnel lundi en fin d'après midi
le chef de l'état s'est adressé au
parlement au complet pour rappeler
notamment à l'unité nationale
on a là oui je crois
discours d'une très grande très grande
force et qu'elle natura
donner de la chair à l'unité nationale
l'international qui se discutent pas un
point important aussi sûr
la question la coalition internationale
autour une seule et unique coalition
internationale autour de la lutte contre
d'âge même s'il a rappelé que pour nous
ce qui nous différencie d'autres pays
bachar al assad n'était pas la solution
aussi initialement prévu pour deux jours
l'état d'urgence pourrait être prolongé
de trois mois avec un projet de loi
présenté mercredi au parlement trois
mois je ne sais pas si ça suffit mais en
même temps je pense qu'il est
indispensable d'avoir de prendre les
mesures qui ont été précisés c'est aussi
des perquisitions ces des mesures de
police supplémentaires savez pas ce qui
résoudra tout mais il faut dans un même
temps
les ajouté autre annonce des renforts
militaires policiers et douaniers avec
un total de huit mille 500 postes créés
d'ici deux ans du côté de l'opposition
si on salue les annonces faites on
regrette le temps perdu
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est le concret
c'est noël c'est la sécurisation de tous
les lieux recevant du public
c'est pour organiser des portiques de
sécurité dans tous les établissements
mettre en cohérence le fonctionnement de
toutes nos forces de sécurité assurer
une meilleure sécurité dans les
transports en rendant obligatoire le
port de la carte d'identité dans ces
transports comme le demandent
aujourd'hui la sncf pour jean frédéric
poisson député du parti
chrétien-démocrate de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines qui
souhaitait un rapprochement avec la
syrie
le disque aurait sans doute de nature à
rassurer les français mais que de temps
perdu sur tout le reste coalition
internationale unifiée déchéance de
nationalité pour les étrangers coupables
d'actes terroristes remise à plat des
accords de schengen et rétablissement
des contrôles aux frontières
modification des conditions d'engagement
des uns des policiers sont demandés
depuis des mois par l'opposition le chef
de l'état souhaite aussi faire évoluer
la constitution rapport avec les
événements
une rencontre avec ses homologues
américain et russe est prévu la semaine
prochaine et dans de nombreuses villes
du département les hommages aux victimes
des attentats de paris qui ont fait je
le rappelle sont 29 morts et 350 blessés
bilan provisoire
ce sont ceux tirés hier toute la journée
à saint cyr l'école un rassemblement
était prévu à 19 heures devant l'hôtel
de ville
patrick jacques de dixmude et sephora
namani se sont rendus sur place en ce
jour je pense que c'est le sentiment de
tous ici nous sommes partagés entre le
chagrin et la colère
c'est par ces mots que le maire de saint
cyr a défini l'émotion de ses
concitoyens lundi soir sur le parvis de
la mairie
après l'horreur place au recueillement
près de 250 habitants de la commune se
sont déplacés afin de rendre hommage aux
victimes des attentats de ce week end
nous sommes tous français quelles que
soient nos origines et nous voulons
montrer à ceux qui ont fait ça et à ceux
qui pourraient avoir l'idée de
recommencer
que nous n'avons pas peur et que la
france elle est une et indivisible
l'émotion était palpable parmi les
participants après une minute de silence
petits et grands ont entonné la
marseillaise accompagné de la fanfare de
la commune c'est ensuite sur le mur des
mots qu'ils ont adressé leur soutien aux
blessés un acte de solidarité qui sera
envoyée aux hôpitaux saint antoine et de
la pitié salpêtrière à paris pour
soutenir les personnes qui sont blessées
pour qu'elle se bat pour rester en vie
et pour leur dire qu'on est là et qu'on
est avec eux il faut être avec ces gens
qui ont tellement souffert
malheureusement pas pour ceux qui sont
partis mais enfin ce qu'ils sont en
train d'offrir les habitants ont ensuite
déposé des fleurs et des bougies sur le
sol comme autant de lumière contre le
terrorisme et nous recevons en plateau
ce soir jean luc tu as dit cela un
président de la croix rouge de saint
quentin en yvelines pour soir avoue
besoin c'est d'être venu sur le plateau
alors vendredi soir pendant les
attentats tragiques de paris qui ont
fait 109 morts et 350 blessés bilan
provisoire vous avez vous la croix rouge
étaient mobilisés dès 21h55 de la croix
rouge française a lancé son dispositif
aramis le plan d'action régional sur
accident multisites avec intervention
spécifique en ile-de-france en appui des
pouvoirs publics et au cours de la nuit
plus de 300 volontaires de la
croix-rouge français sont intervenus
pour porter secours aux victimes
d'ailleurs 70 bénévoles des yvelines
était sur place et 10 de saint quentin
ont été mobilisés comme ça c'est un
petit peu déroulait justement vous avez
été appelé par les pouvoirs publics mais
dire que la croix rouge fait partie du
dd commission d'urgence aussi bien
nationales que régionales ou
départementales et donc nous avons
immédiatement été visé deux
d'un besoin et nous les instructions
étaient de mobiliser le maximum des
clips puisque l'on ne savait pas
exactement où on serait donc nous avons
fait un premier appel nous avons pu
réunir immédiatement
environ 350 bénévoles volontaires parce
qu'on a quelques quelques salariés quand
même qu'ils sont sur paris et nous avons
pu
mobiliser toute une série de véhicules
passe assez bien vu à la télévision
il y avait notamment le l'ambulance de
la cross de saint quentin en yvelines
qui étaient là-bas sur paris pour faire
les transports qui était nécessaire et
donc tous les sites c'est toute une
organisation je vais pas dire militaire
mais presque de contacts systématiques
des bénévoles qui répondent pour donner
leur disponibilité et ensuite qu'ils
sont appelés avec un endroit où il doit
se rendre immédiatement selon l'urgence
avec le véhicule au son de véhicules
dans tous les camps en uniforme est prêt
à assumer les missions qui leur seront
confiées avec des responsables qui ont
sur chaque site sur sur ce responsable
régional qui qui colle qui gère la
totalité du dispositif
or les équipes ont participé au centre
d'accueil de soutien psychologique mise
en place à l'hôtel dieu à paris ainsi
qu'à la mairie du xième arrondissement
voilà leur action justement l'action
dans ce cas là c'est 2 2
recueillir les personnes de les
accompagner de les les mettre en rapport
avec des psychologues parce que nos
bénévoles sont pas on a quelques
bénévoles psychologues ne sont pas tous
se préparer à ça la mission mais bon ne
serait-ce qu accompagner les personnes
les transporter les ramener chez eux
après coup évaluer un peu la gravité de
la situation avec des questionnaires
qu'il qu'ils font passer aux différentes
personnes pour voir l'état réel et
pourrait analyser la situation exacte de
chaque bénéfices personne qui est en
difficulté
c'est une situation inédite donc là pour
la france mais aussi pour vous comment
on réagit va peut-être les bénévoles ils
s'attendaient certainement pas à ça
c'est être compliquée sur place ben
c'était compliqué parce que bon on voit
autant de personnes en situation de
détresse comme on a pu voir cesser dans
tous les cas très compliqué on a on a
fait le maximum pour accompagner les
bénévoles qui sont engagés à la croix
rouge sont là dans tous les cas pour
gérer des situations d'urgence donc là
c'était une situation très extrême mais
on avait déjà connu les problèmes du
mois de janvier on avait déjà participé
à tout ce tout c'est toutes ces actions
donc bon je pas dit que les bénévoles
sont rompues parce qu'on n'est jamais
rompu est telle chose est ce qu'on peut
accepter correctement un jour le
lendemain on va pas d'être capable de le
supporter mais bon
donc on accompagne nos bénévoles
également dans dans la gestion de leur
stress tel qu'il peut apparaître
également éventuellement le plan d'eau
car à nice a été déclenché votre joueur
maturité alors non pour l'instant c'est
terminé puisque les ya plus de
deux sites aramis et multisites et pour
tout ce qui est accident ou entre donc
non c'est terminé
par contre nous nous sommes en renfort
des cellules psychologiques de datel du
ministère pour recevoir tous les appels
des personnes la fois pour les diriger
quand elle recherche d'un proche ou
quand elles ont besoin d'une aide
psychologique aux autres vous avez
justement avait toujours en appui
cette situation voilà veuille à une
nouvelle organisation du coup pour
l'action de la croix rouge en soutien
des pouvoirs publics et qui va durer
peut-être des nouvelles choses qui vont
être mises en place
nous nous réjouissons en fonction des
besoins qui sont exprimés et des
demandes qui sont faites là nous avons
une dizaine de bénévoles à temps complet
en 24 heures sur 24
donc ils sont en équipe par équipe de 5h
ou 6h je crois et donc non nous sommes
on appuie donc un bénévole qui étaient
disponibles et qui avait les qualités
pour le faire ont été sélectionnés et se
sont inscrits et vont répond au centre
de réponse là où celle aurait demandé
d'aller
est-ce que vous voilà en tant que les
associations comme la croix rouge c'est
très important votre action est aussi
très importante dans ce genre de
situation ce qui va avoir des choses qui
vont changer aussi à votre niveau
peut-être au niveau je sais pas
peut-être la formation des bénévoles qui
ne s'attendaient certainement pas à
trouver dans le sprint situations bas
pour l'instant on est dans l'analyse je
ne peux pas savoir je n'ai pas encore
d'informations sur le fait que nous
allons devoir revoir certaines choses
c'est pas impossible
encore que l'organisation est bien rodée
nous avons nous faisons régulièrement
des exercices pour nous participons aux
exercices de sa mue et de des pompiers
éventuellement pour vous faire faire
toutes ces actions en commun
mais bon nous on était dans tous les cas
après pas préparés et personne n'était
préparé à une action aussi dramatique
que celle là un à plusieurs endroits
avec autant de personnes qui soient
prises dans l'étau de ces terroristes
est ce que peut être un plan d'action va
être maître parce qu'on a vu que les
habitants ont réagi kahn est assez
rapidement vous même vous avez agi assez
rapidement
il ya des choses qui vont être mises en
place justement pour un meilleur
fonctionnement avec les hôpitaux
six associations à nerfs se reproduire
vu que voilà on est toujours en état
d'urgence sexuel ni écoutés comme vous
le dites ça quand même relativement bien
fonctionné donc
on va essayer de gommer les petites
imperfections qu'on a pu trouver à
droite ou à gauche
nous ici sont 50 ans deux véhicules qui
sont prêts à partir avec tout le
matériel et on serait connu une demi
heure tout est tout est prêt et tout
autour les bénévoles ont rejoint le le
local et nous avons tout le matériel qui
est nécessaire oxygène pense m'enfin bon
tout ce qu'est tout ce qui est fait des
filateurs tout le matériel qui est
nécessaire pour pouvoir aider donc
encore une fois on va analyser là c'est
un peu trop récent
pour savoir vraiment ce qui a bien
fonctionné au mal fonctionné ou dans les
grandes lignes on n'est pas trop
mécontent du fonctionnement
jeudi on va analyser vraiment chaque
équipe a fait cesser ces remonter de
rapports pour dire ce qui avait
fonctionné ce qui n'est pas fonctionné
donc on va on va analyser tout ça et non
nous responsable des urgences ont
ensuite prendre les décisions qui sont à
prendre
si vous avez le cep a un message à faire
passer ce qu'il ya plus de vous
attendait peut-être plus de bénévoles
aujourd'hui à pour la croix rouge pour
faire face attestation ce qui a eu un
réveil des consciences par rapport à ça
pour l'instant c'est encore un peu frais
c'est vrai que la croix rouge a pas
beaucoup communiquer c'est pas le moment
de communiquer sur ce re que quand il
s'était aussi dramatique que ça pu
l'être ce week-end mais bien sûr plus on
a de bénévoles formés à un secouriste de
ça prend entre un an un an et demi
au total parce que c'est quand même des
déformations assez pointue et sont des
situations qui sont assez tendus donc on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi et on peut
pas mettre n'importe qui sur le terrain
donc avant de que que qu'un secouriste
puisse vraiment aller sur le terrain
avec des responsabilités il faut qu'ils
aient été formés spécifiquement donc
comme ce sont principalement des jeunes
que les jeunes par principe
ben ça bouge ça se marie savez c'est des
ménages ça s'apprend des emplois et
l'éventuelle m'en éloigner donc on a à
tort d'avoir relativement important et
donc on est toujours en recherche de
nouveaux bénévoles dans cette activité
là où dans les autres
merci beaucoup à jean luc ghislain date
revenir sur le plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions nous saluons
bien évidemment votre action et le
courage de tous les bénévoles de la
croix rouge et enfin après les tragiques
attentats du vendredi 13 novembre à
paris les français se sont mobilisés et
vous étiez nombreux à vous déplacer
spontanément pour donner votre sang
conséquence le fs l'établissement
français du don du sang à enregistrer
des dons rodez dont record pardon comme
au centre hospitalier de versailles
regardez plus de deux sondes ont
enchaîné ce samedi c'est presque deux
fois plus que d'habitude pour ce jour de
la semaine
par solidarité pour les victimes des
attentats tragiques de vendredi à paris
ils sont nombreux à s'être déplacés pour
certains ce n'est pas dans leurs
habitudes
je l'avais jamais donné avant parce que
tout simplement depuis je suis majeur
fin j'avais pas mal de piercing de
tatouage et avec ce qu'ils demandent
c'est trop de restrictions nous du coup
c'était pas possible de le faire
puis là sa voix c'est vraiment les
événements de ce week-end la première
phase c'était charlie hebdo pareil moi
j'ai mon école qui est juste la place de
république donc carrément on était venu
dans notre école pour participer au don
du sang
donc c'était la première fois et là du
coup c'était la deuxième fois sur toute
la france neuf mille dons ont été
enregistrés
un record pour le f s plus habitué à
recenser deux mille donateurs habituels
les stocks ont permis en ile-de-france
de gérer les besoins actuels pour les
blessés des attentats
l'établissement a reçu suffisamment de
dons mais appelle ses donateurs à rester
mobilisés nous allons avoir besoin de
ces mêmes donneurs spontanée dans les
trois semaines qui viennent voir quatre
semaines tous les blessés de vendredi
vont subir des interventions
chirurgicales
là pour le coup régler et non pas
d'urgence c'est ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dans les hôpitaux c'est la
chirurgie de guerre donc on a fait à
l'urgence maintenant il ya toute la
chirurgie réparatrice abdominale et
thoracique et leur taupe et dick et
l'abominable thoracique
ça consomme du sens même avec les
meilleures techniques les donneurs
spontanée de samedi ne pourront être
prélevés avant le 15 janvier l'opérateur
de transfusion français espère que cet
élan de solidarité sera durable et
compte aussi sur ses habitués les
attentats
c'était un prétexte pour revenir encore
une fois mais on donne tous les trois
mois environ et
je pense que c'était important c'est
surtout important pour les premiers
donneurs qui font leurs gardes qui après
reviennent aussi régulièrement quand
nous ont bien mais on est trop peu à
venir il faut attendre huit semaines
entre chaque prélèvement de sang c'est
pourquoi le ffs appelle plutôt les
donneurs à venir comment les vacances de
noël une période creuse habituellement
et vous l'avez entendu plus de 9000
candidats au don de sang se sont
présentés sur les lieux de collectes
partout en france ce samedi 14 novembre
le f est né bien sûr à les remercier
pour l'instant les collectes mobiles
sont interrompus pour cause de sécurité
mais pourraient reprendre dès jeudi
l'établissement français du sang invite
donc les donneurs à continuer à se
mobiliser dans les prochains jours et
les prochaines semaines et rappelle que
dix mille dons sont nécessaires chaque
jour et enfin toujours suite aux
attentats de vendredi le plan blanc a
été déclenché dans tous les
établissements hospitaliers du
département
un dispositif de mobilisation maximale
prévue pour les situations sanitaires
d'urgence de crise
inscrit dans la loi depuis 2004 il
permet aux établissements de santé
publics et privés d'organiser
immédiatement les moyens humains et
matériels pour faire face à l'afflux des
patients ou des victimes en demande
notamment le retour des médecins et
infirmières sur leurs jours de repos
c'est dans cette petite boutique de
saint quentin en yvelines que des
bénévoles s'activent pour venir en aide
aux familles démunies de l'agglomération
son nom baldeschi elle fête ses 20 ans
d'existence cette semaine l'une des
belles récompenses qu'on peut avoir
c'est les visites de familles qui
reviennent nous voir pour nous dire
bakel se sont elles sont sorties de la
difficulté où elle était quelle qu'elles
se trouvent bien quand il nous arrive de
faire une collecte alimentaire
on peut rencontrer aussi des familles
qui se montrent d'ailleurs
particulièrement généreux et qui sont
passés par balise qui l'association
s'adresse aux familles en difficulté
porteuse d'un projet ayant besoin d'une
aide temporaire est désolé pour ce petit
problème technique nous recevront en
plateau dominique servais président de
la balise qui les images que vous venez
de voir ben les skis c'est une boutique
alimentaire qui contribuent également au
projet de réinsertion des familles
connaissant des difficultés alors pour
les 20 ans de l'association bel esprit
nous sommes allés faire un tour dans
votre association justement une
trentaine de bénévoles travaillent dans
cette boutique qui procure des produits
aliments
r et d'hygiène à prix réduits sani
bourdillon et patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est dans cette petite boutique de
saint quentin en yvelines que des
bénévoles s'activent pour venir en aide
aux familles démunies de l'agglomération
son nom bas les skis elle fête ses 20
ans d'existence cette semaine l'une des
belles récompenses qu'on peut avoir
c'est les visites de familles qui
reviennent nous voir pour nous dire
qu'elle se sont elles sont sorties de la
difficulté où elle était quelle qu'elles
se trouvent bien quand il nous arrive de
se faire une collecte alimentaire
on peut rencontrer aussi des familles
qui se montrent d'ailleurs
particulièrement généreux et qui sont
passés leurs balises qui l'association
s'adresse aux familles en difficulté
porteuse d'un projet ayant besoin d'une
et temporaires elle doit sa notoriété
depuis 20 ans au financement de nombreux
contributeurs
l'association bénéficie de dons déjà du
conseil général de la caisse qui des
quatre communes
on a des familles donc
montigny-le-bretonneux
voisins-le-bretonneux et
magny-les-hameaux guyancourt on a des
dons privés aussi qui viennent des
entreprises et puisqu'ils organisent
tout au long de l'année
régulièrement des spectacles un concert
de jazz kosar de piano il ya des pièces
de théâtre donc ça nous fait
effectivement un apport de fonds qui
permet à bas les skis de pouvoir joindre
les deux bouts
tous les mois balises qui peut
accueillir 54 familles sur 3 mois
renouvelable ce qui représente 500
personnes chaque année
re bonsoir d'amitié servait alors vous
êtes le président de dalles estime merci
à d'être venu ce notre plateau alors on
a vu un petit un reportage nous
présentons à l'action de l'association
alors c'est une boutique alimentaire
mais il ya aussi un réel accompagnement
des familles vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus si à coller mais je pense que
les familles ont besoin d'être nourris
quand elles ont des difficultés
financières d'être aidés sur le plan
nourriture mais ils ont aussi besoin
d'être aidés sur le plan de du
comportement de le du respect de et donc
nous sommes amenés avec ces familles a
rencontré ces familles et qui font une
liste de courses de d'épicerie
traditionnel une épicerie ou de soins
d'hygiène etc mais qui ont en même temps
vous rencontrez nos bénévoles qui
s'occupent de deûle et de les écouter de
les comprendre de les aider dans les
dents les dans les démarches de de
papier de santé de droits sociaux etc
voilà donc et éventuellement aussi dans
les démarches de loisirs voilà un petit
peu choisis ces familles est ce qu'on
peut aller directement dans votre
association
pour ce faire un break en menant alors
c'est l'ensemble des familles que nous
recevons nous sont adressées par des
travailleurs sociaux pour qu'ils
travaillent sur ces quatre communes et
qui sont des professionnels avec ses
travailleurs sociaux établissent avec la
famille concernée un projet un projet de
réinsertion puisque nous recevons
essentiellement des familles qui sont en
difficulté mais qui ont une capacité si
on les aide pour faire un petit pas
complémentaires si une capacité à
rebondir et à revenir dans une vie
normale
donc le travailleur social va faire un
projet et va nous adresser ce projet
nous avons une fois par mois à une
commission des familles avec des
bénévoles qui est qui qui ont l'habitude
d'étudier ces dossiers et et nous allons
prendre ce les familles avec comme
objectif que trois mois après la famille
puisse être autonome retrouver une
certaine autonomie
bon il faut pas se leurrer trois mois
après toutes les familles n'ont pas
retrouvé leur autonomie donc on leur
nouvelle normalement une fois
quelquefois par exception on va le
renouveler une fois de plus un peu plus
longtemps
voilà vous fêtez vos vingt ans oui alors
c'est une longévité importante
est-ce que vous avez constaté une
évolution dans votre activité peut-être
une précarité plus importante
oui certainement mais en ce moment
depuis depuis deux ou trois ans on sent
qu'ils elles et qui a une précarité plus
importante
on le sent à de deux indices pour nous
c'est d'une part que des familles
consacrent plus de budget il reste un
petit peu plus longtemps
c'est à dire qu'elles ont plus de mal à
ressortir de la difficulté
et puis l'autre aspect aussi c'est que
et ça c'est un aspect qu'il est
difficile pour nous c'est que certaines
familles ne vont pas venir parce que
elles n'ont pas suffisamment d'argent
pour participer au montant de
participation qui leur est demandé chez
nous c'est c'est de l'ordre de 40 % à 45
% du prix normal en boutique en
supermarché si vous voulez donc c'est ça
n'est pas de l'aide d'urgence que nous
faisons ce que nous sommes nous sommes
sur une autre une autre d'un autre mène
mais et les familles éventuellement vont
avoir besoin d'eux pour aller en aide
d'urgence où la houle et elles peuvent
avoir de quoi manger
je répondais pour des montants le très
très limité alors il nous arrive bien
sûr de donner à des familles qui n'ont
pas de quoi se nourrir de donner quelque
chose mais c'est l'exception c'est pas
c'est pas le fonctionnement normal de
notre boutique
alors comment à souhait comment fait-on
si on souhaite pas rendre le devenir
bénévole fait certainement en recherche
de bénévoles peut-être de dons également
pour l'association
eh bien on s'adresse à la boutique
alimentaire baby ski qui a un site
internet
badis qui pointent enfin si on fait dans
google car ici on trouve le site
internet je connais plus barca mais qui
est à la maison louis jouvet à la sueur
de riz sur montigny et et puis on l'a on
rencontre la responsable qui a
l'habitude de devoir les bénévoles et en
fonction des périodes et des besoins
on va on va accueillir des bénévoles
avec grand plaisir plus de plus de
besoin comment la période de noël qui
arrive est une perle direct à plus de 9
ans oui mais on peut passer il ya quand
même besoin d'eux quand on est bénévole
il faut il faut s'intégrer dans l'équipe
parce que c'est c'est tout un ensemble
de respect des personnes donc maintenant
on a il ya des bénévoles mais il ya
aussi des personnes qui nous aident
comme par exemple on a fait cette année
en liaison avec d'autres associations
une opération de deux de commandes de
soins de beauté pour les femmes c'est
quelque chose de très fort pour des
personnes qui n'ont plus de quoi se on
s'aperçoit que c'est c'est quelque chose
qui marque beaucoup et là on a eu on a
des personnes qui ne sont pas bénévoles
en permanence mais qui sont venus nous
aider pour faire cette ses soins de
beauté
merci beaucoup dominique elle servait je
le rappelle donc la version pagny la
boutique fête ses 20 ans et enfin le
festival à saint quentin été inauguré
jeudi dernier à l'ugc skywest avec en
avant première la diffusion de demain
documentaire réalisé par mélanie laurent
et scierie dion un événement qui a
rassemblé quatre cent soixante dix
personnes cependant la programmation du
festival n'a pas pu être maintenu dans
son intégralité en raison des tragiques
attentats de vendredi conduisant à la
fermeture des salles de spectacles
retour sur le bilan de ce festival avec
sephora mamani et william l jeudi
dernier et est inaugurée à l'ugc skywest
le festival 5
un festival de documentaires autour de
la thématique de l'environnement pour
cette première édition
projet initié par tv fil 78 ce festival
a pour vocation de rassembler les
acteurs locaux et de proposer un autre
regard sur le monde
rassemblés sur un moment là en
l'occurrence sur quatre jours des
établissements très différents avec
lequel on travaille avec lesquels on ne
travaille pas forcément tfx a aussi un
acteur du territoire mais bien de la
travail que les autres sur ce moment
l'important c'est de fédérer autour d'un
événement culturel au sens large que ce
soit des salles de films de cinéma de
spectacle ou d'autres lieux comme les
universités pour pouvoir créer un
événement qui est un peu différent de ce
qu'on peut vivre dans un cinéma
classique et de pouvoir faire participer
un public dans différents lieux du
territoire
initialement prévu du 12 au 15 novembre
le festival devait proposer outre les
projections de documentaires des débats
expositions ainsi que des ateliers
pratiques
ouvert au public pour s'initier aux
différentes techniques de cadrage un
projet qui a su fédérer le public c'est
toujours revient quand la relation qui
se crée ça fait bouger les limites de
du regard je trouvais que ce festival
est le cri film comme un devoir imposé
de belle intégration sur la réalité du
monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est l'occasion demande de penser à
autre chose est de voir des films qui
peuvent changer des choses c'est bien
que ça fait ici ça change que cette
tendance est à paris cependant toute la
programmation n'a pu être retenu en
raison des attentats tragiques de
vendredi la cérémonie de remise des prix
a été reporté mais en attendant les prix
décernés sont les suivants prix tv fil
pour cobra gipsy prix des cinémas à
prisonniers volontaires de la banquise
et enfin le prix troisième revient à
hamoudia et c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis je vous donne rendez vous demain
à 18 heures pour une nouvelle édition du
ces fuites le journal en direct
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée